okay good so so welcome everyone and uh
yeah today
um we have we have Sam Gunn speaking um
Sam's uh Sam's a PhD student here in
Berkeley and um you might know him of
course from from the famous Aaronson gun
paper which he wrote as an undergrad but
but since then you know he's already
been doing a lot of interesting work uh
uh you know uh of various kinds
including committing to Quantum States
and then this paper that he's going to
talk about today the the work that he's
going to talk about today is I think
it's really very interesting work you
know solving a a major question in
Quantum American acting quotes but but
um uh but what's very interesting about
it is it's a purely student
paper you know Sam and Thiago and Louis
so uh uh so looking forward to the talk
Simon
peace yeah thanks so much
um so yeah so uh I'm Sam
um I'm gonna talk a little bit about
some interesting aspects of approximate
uh Quantum American codes
so okay so first let's just talk about
uh what do we mean by air correction and
by approximate error correction so the
idea is we're going to have some message
row which could either be classical or
Quantum but for this talk of course it's
mostly going to be usually going to be a
Quantum State
um and we want to encode it into some
code word
um which is going to be you know a
larger a larger uh string and then some
errors might happen to it so we're going
to like imagine sending this code word
across some noisy Channel where some
errors happen According to some air
model and then we want to be able to
decode it back to the original message
okay so there's there's sort of two
extrema models of errors that we could
consider
um so at one end there's there's uh
there's Erasure errors
so this is where a few of the the
registers or the symbols basically just
like drop out of your code word or and
then um in the decoding algorithm should
get to see which ones disappeared so
they're like as in no which ones
disappeared and then they can the
decoding algorithm can just decode from
the remaining registers okay so this is
sort of one model of errors and then I
sort of at The Other Extreme we could
imagine in adversary who gets to go and
access some uh some some limited number
of registers of the code word and then
do whatever they want to them so the
adversary can tamper them however they
want with these register however they
want and uh potentially even in an
Unbound computationally unbounded way
um so and here we're not going to assume
that the decoding algorithm gets to even
know which registers the adversary
corrupted okay so these are sort of two
basic models of Errors
um and the usual notion of uh that we
require from our air curtain codes is
that you know uh we can exactly recover
the message so after even after the
adversary attached temperatures of some
bounded number of registers we should be
able to perfectly recover the message
that we started with but in this talk
we're going to be more interested where
we're going to be focused on what we can
do with approximate error correction
which is now we're only going to require
the deconing algorithm to recover the
message up to some small error say
epsilon
so in particular we're going to really
want Epsilon to be like exponentially
small so like you would never notice
that you weren't perfectly recovering
your messages it's as if you just did
them you know perfectly yeah so um
another thing that we want is we want
our symbols or registers to have
constant size so these these black
circles represent you know the pieces of
the physical system so for example maybe
bits on your computer or qubits or
cudits
um and the reason behind why we want
them to have constant size is that you
can imagine you know you want to be able
to send these messages over some Channel
and uh you have to have some physical
implementation of your channel and you
don't want the like physics physical
system that you're using to have to
change along with the the like file size
of the thing that you want to send or
the state the size of the state that you
want to send so uh yeah so you don't
want your symbols to have to to like for
example become really large as you get a
large file
um
so uh and then finally we're going to be
interested in getting good rates so the
rate is just the ratio of the number of
symbols in the message to the number of
symbols in the code word so if you have
a high rate it means that it's like an
efficient code uh meaning that you know
for every bit that I every register that
I send over the channel I'm you know
sending a lot of information
okay so um these sort of two air models
that we talked about erasures and like
adversarial errors are uh sort of
captured by two parameters In classical
code or sorry in in uh in in for codes
called the distance and decoding radius
so
um the distance is the number of uh
erasures that you can tolerate and the
decoding radius is the number of
adversarial areas you can tolerate so
there's actually is a picture for this
that explains these words in the
classical setting at least where
um you could imagine uh all of these
blue dots are like classical code words
and living in some space in with where
the metric is like the Hamming distance
um so the distance is going to be the
minimum distance between any two
codewords and the decoding radius is the
is like the maximum amount that you can
perturb from a code word and then still
be able to go back be able this decoding
item should still be able to uniquely
figure out which code word you came from
so again all in Hamming distance
so that's sort of where this uh these
terms the economics and distance come
from
um uh so yeah so here's just uh
operationally we're going to sort of use
these in the green notion in the green
box where distance is the number of your
issues and two corners is a number of
errors in terms of these are these
equivalents these Notions are the same
at least for decoding radius I think it
should be clear
um so okay it's a fact that for
classical aircraft encodes the decoding
radius is always at most half the
distance
um so you can sort of see that from the
picture
uh and turns out this is also true for
exact Quantum error correction codes
and we'll actually I'll try to sketch a
proof of this uh in a few slides
um like an outline of a proof of this so
our result is that there uh we show that
there exists approximate Quantum codes
for the decoding radius actually is all
the way up to almost the distance for
all rates and uh with a constant
alphabet so still in the setting of the
previous slide
okay so let's uh let's get some more
background uh and talk about our results
um so first there's this there's like
one basic upper bound on how well you
can build a code called the Quantum Code
called the quantum Singleton band so
this says that no Quantum error
correcting code of rate R can correct
more than one minus r over two fraction
of erasers
so for example if you set R really small
like R equals zero then this is saying
that no error correction code can
correct more than half fraction of
erasures so this follows from just like
the no cloning theorem right if you
could correct from half of your ratios
that means that you could you know take
your your message encode it in the code
word and then decode the the message
completely from each half separately and
get two copies of it okay so um
so in fact this is more General thing
that whole it's more General around the
quantum sanction Mount holding for all R
uh follows from sort of similar
reasoning so let's let's see that now so
suppose that you have a code with
distance D meaning it can handle D minus
20 ratios so let's try to clone it let's
do our best at climbing it we'll get a
bound out of the fact that we can't
clone it so first let's encode it into
our code word now let's take some uh D
minus one registers of our codeword and
then let's like set them aside and take
them over here
so now in this first code word we still
have all that D minus one of the
registers so by because we're assuming
the code is distance D that means we can
completely decode the message from this
part alone
okay but then now we're trying to clone
it uh but this bottom part doesn't
actually have enough registers to you
know we don't have all but n but D minus
one of the registers so what do we do
well we just guess the remaining ones so
that's these yellow ones let's just say
that you just like randomly guess these
these remaining registers and then just
try to decode this anyway even though uh
you know we we guessed part of the code
so the number of vertices we had to
guess is going to be this n minus 2 D
minus 1. and basically uh because we had
a message of length K we don't we
shouldn't have any way to uh to convert
the problem of guessing the message of
length K into a problem of guessing
fewer registers
so because of this uh the size of the
message should be at most the number of
addresses we had to guess so this I just
wrote that out here such as k at most n
minus at most the the number of yellow
registers that we had to guess for our
code okay and then just rearranging this
equation and then dividing by n gives
you the quantity that's in Bound exactly
um okay
so
uh also as you can kind of see from that
argument you know there's nothing about
the fact about the exactness of the
codes that that uh that we use so uh
similar arguments extends to the uh
approximate setting where we can show a
robust condom Singleton bound
um so the basketball team vendor says
that even if if you if you allow like an
Epsilon amount of air in your code uh
then
um then you know the Singleton band can
only be violated by like some small
amount depending on Epsilon so uh
technically like we uh couldn't find
this in the literature anyway so uh in
order to show like Titan smell real
sweet had to prove it but
um but it's pretty much an extension of
the existing arguments
so um
uh okay so then for the second part I
told you that there's a relationship
it's in the decoding radius in the
distance at least for exact codes so
this is for exact Quantum codes
and also classical codes
um so we said that the decoding rate is
the most half the distance so on this
side let me try to give you like a super
high level sketch of of the argument for
how this goes so what we want to show is
that if you have decoding radius R
meaning you can correct from R
adversarial errors then we want to show
that your distance has to be at least 2R
okay so the way I see that is if you're
if you're assuming we have some code
with decoding radius R then for any two
encodings PSI and five orthogonal
messages
um an adversary acting on R registers
alone shouldn't be able to sort of make
make uh sort of equivocate between these
they shouldn't be able to make these two
things these two orthogonal messages
look the same or even look at all
indistinguishable
so here I've just written that down what
it means mathematically so if you say
you start off with a state PSI and the
adversary applies some operation V of
weight R to psi and then some other
operation W to Phi then um you know
these states should still be orthogonal
the resulting sisters will be orthogonal
so um now if you take some unitary
action to our registers you can
decompose it into a sum of exponentially
many
um tensor products of registers acting
on on R registers each of two two yeah
operations act on our registers each
and
um by this equation up here uh this has
to be zero
so in roughly this means that losing to
our registers doesn't remove any
information about your message
so
um uh yeah so this is super high level
but the main point is that is that this
argument went by writing this unitary
in terms of like a sum of exponentially
many terms and when we really use the
fact that they were all zero so this is
not going to extend to approximate codes
because as soon as you allow any any
notion of approximation then
um
uh you know you're not going to get all
these terms to be zero even if each of
these terms is exponentially small the
sum could still be large so basically
this this inequality that decoding rate
is almost half the distance is just not
going to hold in the in the um
approximate case
um
okay so now with these upper bounds
let's look at how our result compares to
these other brands
um so uh for every so okay so for the
balance that we just saw this this
Quantum column right here which says
that the distance is at most uh one
minus r by two that's the quantum
Singleton bound and then by applying
this bound from the previous side we can
see that uh that the decoding radius is
almost half of that
okay
um and then the classical Singleton
bound uh in is like twice as half as bad
so so that's the the classical column so
now what we're going to see is so in the
approximate Quantum setting as I said
before the the robust Quantum Singleton
bound still applies so this first row is
still going to hold we still have that
the distance is at most one minus r over
two
but now the second column we don't have
any any better bound on it than that all
we know is that the decoding rate is at
most the distance
um so namely you know an adversary could
always just erase the registers they're
given so you can't tolerate more adverse
errors than you have distance so so uh
and then the interesting thing that we
show is that this bound is actually
typed so we're going to show that we can
get we're going to construct codes that
um uh have decoding radius all the way
approaching the Singleton the quantum
Singleton bound
um so all of these these in the right
column are all up to Small additive
factors
okay moreover our codes are going to
have constant alphabet and inverse
exponential error so this is still in
the setting that I described early on
soon
so um one thing to that's maybe kind of
surprising is that this this same
phenomenon can't happen classically so
if you choose if you chose a small rate
then
um you can get classical codes which
have distance like uh almost the entire
code so
um
uh namely
um you know you could have like you
could encode your message into some
codeword delete almost the entire code
word and then you could still recover
the message uniquely from whatever's the
small amount that's left
um uh but you can't hope to do the same
thing with decoding radius so now if you
don't erase the registers but if an
adversary were to tamper with almost all
the registers then they could always
just replace whatever registers they
have with like a valid encoding of some
fresh message and you would never notice
the difference
so um so uh so you're never going to get
classical decoding radius all the way up
to the distance
um yeah so um okay and in fact this is
sort of motivation behind uh list
decoding
um classically uh which is to get uh
codes which in some sense have decoding
radius all the way up to the distance
okay so um this is our result again but
a little more formally so for any like
constant slots for any constant slack
parameter gamma and any rate R we're
going to construct codes with rate R
decoding radius gamma off of the
Singleton bound and inverse exponential
error in constant alphabet where the
alphabet's going to going to grow with
the slack parameter which how much slack
you want off of the Singleton found
um
so compared to previous work
um this work of crepo goddessman and
Smith in 2005 sort of handled the gamma
equals zero and R about or gamma
approximate zero and R approximately
zero case
um so they show that you can have codes
where the decoding radius is all the way
up to basically
um a half but they're going to have
exponential alphabet
um so uh yeah so in other words like the
the the size of the registers that you
need to send has to grow
like uh very like linearly with the the
um size of the messages that you want to
encode
okay and then
another work of lung and Smith
talk about the binary alphabet case so
they talk about a similar question
but um
but their algorithm is going to have
inefficient decoding
um so they're going to describe and
they're also not going to reach the
Singleton bound
because uh they only handle binary
alphabets and you can't hope to give
this thing to demand with not alphabets
family
yeah so once again
okay
so uh now let me talk a little bit about
our techniques
um okay so one of the the main ideas
behind our uh of our construction is uh
list decoding so let me describe what
list decoding is at least in the
classical case first
so if you take
um so in uh in air correction you have
some some code word X and then some
error gets applied to it and then you
want to be able to decode it to
um normally you want to decode back to X
but for list decoding we're going to say
that you're just going to Output your
decoding algorithm just has to Output a
list of L possible code words
and we just require that um that the
true code word is in the list so uh and
then in order for it to be a good
listing list decoding algorithm you want
L to be like polynomial so you want
there to be not like huge lists and then
uh yeah
um so a little bit more formally a code
is Delta L is decodable if for all
corrupted code words there's a most L
possible decodings within you know the
specified distance Delta sorry
um okay so uh so Guru Swami and rudra
showed in 2005 that there exists
classical codes that are list decodable
from errors all the way up to almost to
the classical Singleton bound of one
minus r
so while you can't hope to uniquely
recover your message from adversarial
errors on almost the entire uh codeword
you can hope to list Dakota to Output a
list that contains a message
um okay
um
so naturally we're going to have to
think about sort of a Quantum version of
list decoding so uh Quantum this
economics introduced by long and Smith
in 2008 I mentioned this work earlier
and then we use a slightly different
definition but it's kind of the same
idea uh so
um we don't expect to be able to produce
the list of decoded States uh because
that would sort of seem to violate some
sort of uh um no cloning intuition
but uh instead what we're going through
is we're going to to produce a list of
possible errors that could have happened
so a list of classical descriptions of
errors that could have happened to our
codeword
um okay so uh formerly uh we say that a
Quantum Code is Delta list decodable if
um for all low weight errors the
decoding procedure produces a list of
the possible errors that could have
happened so maybe for you could imagine
like measuring the stabilizer or
measuring the syndrome of a code word
and then classically from the syndrome
classically Computing the list of
possible Corrections and then you want
that there's a small list which includes
the real correction
um
so uh okay so now with with quantities
according in hand we can start to talk
about
how we construct our approximate codes
um so uh the first step is we're going
to authenticate our message with um some
sort of authentication algorithm so that
means we're going to sample random keys
k and then authenticate the message
using K and what authentication is going
to do is it's going to it's going to
allow us to detect errors if they happen
on the authenticated message so as long
as the keys that we use are kept hidden
from the error Channel
um our authenticator is going to like
sort of flag errors for us okay then
we're going to combine then after we
authenticate we're going to encode the
message in the least decodable I'm so
sorry sorry Sam um just to go back to
the authentication
um so the authentication will only tell
you
that the message is is unchanged or
whether some error happened it won't
identify an error for you yes I want to
identify an error yes yes oh did I if I
said that that's uh that was a mistake
uh yeah sorry so the the authenticator
will just tell you whether an error
happens or not right yeah okay thanks so
much
um so uh yeah
um so after we authenticate
um we're going to encode the
authenticated message into our list
Equitable code
and then okay and this is kind of a
common technique classically to get to
boost list decoding to something uh to
Unique to coding where you you
authenticate and then you encode and
let's see order code because now
whenever you prepare this list you can
sort of sieve the list and figure out
which element and list is the was the
the valid is the real is the real
message right okay uh of course the
issue is that now you have these Keys
laying around authentication requires
you to to send these keys to know what
the keys are to check the authentication
as well
um uh so how do we get these keys to the
recipient without getting the channel to
without like hand accidentally giving
them to the channel
um to the adversarial Channel The Air
Channel
um well we use this thing called uh
robust secret sharing so it's a totally
classical concept
and essentially what it does is exactly
what we want it just it's uh it's like a
version of a classical like a randomized
uh classical error correction
um air correcting code
um where it also not only does it let
you recover uh the the thing the the
keys it also keeps them secret from uh
from any error Channel That's only given
a you know a bounded number of the of
the registers
so okay so we're going to to write it
down like we're going to robust secret
share our keys and then we're going to
sort of append them on uh register by
register to the uh Quantum list decoded
uh uh encoded message
so our registers are going to increase
by like a constant Factor
um but it's it's all going to be okay
these these Robotics are sharing uh uh
symbols are gonna we're gonna be able to
choose them to be relatively small so
okay
so in a little bit more detail what we
mean by a Quantum authentication is
called purity testing codes so it's not
quite the normal notion of quantum
authentication but it's it's related
um so what we want is that for any error
E that happens the probability that the
error is an undetectable error on the
authenticated message is at most Alpha
for some small Alpha
okay in these uh uh so so basically if
any error happens to the authenticated
message then
um even if the air is the high weight
then we'll we'll pick it up we'll
observe it
um as long as we have the correct Keys
um okay so these are known to exist good
constructions and um yeah we just have
to make sure the adversary doesn't see
the keys
so okay the way uh so the other
ingredient the robustica sharing scheme
is a completely classical object
um uh which has sort of two requirements
so first is robustness
um which says that you can recover the
method of high probability so here this
is just it's kind of the same setting as
error correction where you encode an
adversary acts on some registers and
then you decode
but um in addition to this robustness
that you can recover the message uh we
want secrecy so the message should be
completely random conditioned on the
view of the adversary of any adversary
given on the about a number of the
registers
so this result of Kramer demguard.ling
fair and spinning from crypto 2015.
says that there exists really good robot
secret sharing schemes that are going to
be uh more than good enough for our
purposes
so yeah I won't get into these
parameters but they uh yeah they'll be
good to know so
we're turning to our um our Construction
now once we have a good authentication
algorithm a good robot secret sharing
scheme in a good uh Quantum listing
codable code we can stick them all
together in this way and we'll get a
good approximate Quantum error
correction code
so here if the authenticator has small
air has like exponentially small error
Alpha and the signaturing scheme has X
symmetry small error beta and the lists
are only polynomial large then we'll
have an exponentially good exponentially
small error in our approximate Quantum
American code with unique decoding
um okay so the remaining part uh prior
Works handled you know existing
techniques handle
um the authentication in the secret
sharing part
so the only thing we have to do is uh
come up with a good
um list Quantum this decodable code
okay
so in order to do that
um we're going to heavily rely on this
sort of uh classical cons old
construction of quantum uh error
correcting codes called CSS codes from
Carter Bank Shore and steam
um so what these do is given two linear
classical codes C1 and C2 which are
going to have some certain properties
related to each other that we don't need
to get into I'm sorry uh sorry Sam could
you could you say what you what what
what are the conditions you need from
the list decoding uh you know because
you said well there's already existing
Quantum list decodable code so why do
you need new ones and oh oh what
parameters are you looking for yeah so
we want parameters reaching the the
quantum Singleton band so we want uh you
know so these These are the parameters
that we want
um basically if we have a list of code
of a code which has decoding radius all
the way up to here which has like list
decoding radius all the way up to the
quantum Singleton bound then the sort of
like wrapper that I described just a
minute ago is gonna let us convert this
into a unique decoding code so yes yeah
great great question the basically we
want this decoding up to uh
so in some sense of the same thing we
had classically right list decoding
takes you from
unique decoding radius to distance uh
Quantum this decoding is also going to
take us from uh you know uh yeah so so
is it correct that if you if you if you
if you wanted to you could also say what
you what you're doing is is achieving
list decoding up to this this this
radius this this bound and then there's
a icing on the cake which is actually
the the final result which is which is
getting an actual error correcting code
also yeah exactly exactly yeah which
which yeah I think is is kind of
surprising because you know classically
it's like this you need list decoding to
go between these quantumally we're going
to use this decoding in order to
construct these codes but then somehow
at the end they're gonna not be
necessary anymore
um yeah okay so uh very good questions
um
um oh yeah and you asked about okay it
probably works do uh code so the only
prior works that construct list
incredible codes is this long and Smith
paper where they construct uh listed
codable codes for binary alphabets but
uh the main problems are one that
they're not going to there's no
efficient algorithm for actually
decoding them so just kind of like an
information theoretically existence
thing and then also since they're only
over binary alphabets they won't
actually reach this um Quantum Singleton
bound
um
okay
so uh
uh
okay so yeah so
okay so uh I was talking about CSS codes
um so uh yeah so CSS construction is
some way to take
um two classical codes and sort of like
Stitch them together and make one
Quantum Code it's going to inherit a lot
of the properties of the classical codes
um okay so then uh really the important
uh thing about CSS codes that we need is
that correcting errors
uh is a very simple operation that goes
as follows so first all you have you
correct errors on on like one of the
codes and then you're going to apply the
quantum Fourier transform separately to
each register
and then you're going to correct errors
on the other code so it's sort of like
like
um yeah there will be like you know like
logic like regular standard basis errors
on one code and then uh phase errors in
the other code in the qf2 will let you
go between them so you can correct both
[Music]
um okay and then it's the theorem of
quadranging ensure that uh that if if uh
C1 and the Dual of C2 both correct our
errors then the CSS composition corrects
ours so really the important thing
takeaway is just that if you have if C1
and C2 are good codes then the CSS code
is going to inherit is going to also
like inherit similar properties and also
be strong code so um uh
okay so this you know suggests an
obvious way of getting Quantum uh list
of quotable codes which is if you take
you just take C1 and C2 to be classical
these two quotable codes and CSS them
together and now you've got a quadratic
blow up in the list size but it's still
going to be like a polynomial
um uh uh the circuitable Quantum Code
so okay so why does this work well for
each potential error on C2 there's L
errors in C1 so now in the step one
instead of correcting the errors
uniquely will you construct you come up
with a list of L possible errors that
could have happened then apply the Q of
T and now you just have another list of
L possibilities for each element error
that could have happened on C2 you have
L possible errors that could happen with
C1 so in total you still have uh yeah
you still have L squared uh possible
errors okay
so Guru Swami and rudra as I mentioned
before showed in 2005 that
um a certain folded classical codes can
be uh efficiently decoded all the way up
to the classical Singleton bound so
folding is just some operation that
we'll talk we'll get into in a minute
but
um
it has the issue that folding does not
produce linear codes anymore so if you
recall from the previous side in order
to even Define the CSS composition of
two codes they both have to be linear
and and have to assess them more
proteins but the very least have to be
linear
um so this folding doesn't appear that
it's to be useful at least at first and
in fact this is a more General issue we
don't know of any linear codes that can
be efficiently list decoded up to the
classical symptom run
um
okay
so uh so we seem to be kind of stuck
but um let's see let's look at what
folding does anyway so uh if you take if
you take a code word uh uh then folding
what folding does is it basically groups
together
um registers of your code word and then
just redefines these as new registers
and then everything really Remains the
Same so uh so essentially it's like it's
like restricting the adversary's
Behavior Uh so for example you start
with a code with you know with six
um six registers then you fold it then
then maybe you'd get a code with three
registers where each register got a
quadratic blow up in size uh so now
whereas the address area before could
choose any subset of these six registers
to attack now the adversary has to can
only choose subsets of these three
registers and then has to attack them in
sort of bursts together
okay so this is what folding is
but notice that folding is like a
completely syntactic operation right
you're really just redefining what a
register is so folding Quantum codes is
just as well defined as as following
classical codes you can imagine just
redefining Quantum registers instead of
redefining classical registers
so let's uh let's just try that let's
take a Let's Fold a CSS code and then
see what uh what happens and it turns
out that if you fold a CSS code then the
result is going to be the code where
both of the the classical codes sort of
look folded from the perspective of your
decoding algorithm okay so let me I have
a little graphic to try to illustrate
this so say you have this folded code
word and say errors happen on this first
block here
so now uh you know first remember the
decoding algorithm for a CSS or the
correction algorithm for a CSS code is
to First correct uh you know errors in
the standard basis here so we're going
to get rid of these errors here and then
we apply the Q of T and then the phaser
errors show up in the standard basis so
now we can see that you know maybe
there's errors here again
and now we're just going to correct uh C
uh C2 in the same way so notice that
both C1 both of the correcting C1 and
the correcting C2 phases
um uh what we were looking at was just
like a folded classical code in the
standard basis
so uh in other words like from the
perspective of of these two Corrections
right we did we had folded codes
um so it follows uh and this is one of
the main observations one of the first
main observations in our work is that
um you know folded Quantum codes uh work
well with CSS codes so if CSS if C1 and
C2 are classical codes where the
foldings are both highly listed codable
then if you fold the resulting CSS code
you'll get something that's Quantum
effectively less decodable
so this is even though folding C1 and
folding C2 does not result in linear
codes folding the CSS composition
um
does work and gets you listed coding
um
okay
so
um sort of the uh okay so we're almost
there at this point
um this will get you codes that uh that
are listed or that are that are at least
equivalent to Singleton bound and then
buy the same wrapping argument that we
had the wrapping Army that I showed
earlier we can and get approximate air
correcting codes that are uniquely
decodable all the way up to the
Singleton bound the quantum Singleton
band
but there's still one issue which is
that the alphabet size is going to be
polynomial if we instantiate this with
like good uh list of codable
um uh classical codes in the CSS code
um so this would still be new but uh but
we can do a little better and the way we
do this is we borrow a technique of Elon
Edmonds and Luby which is like a
classical technique in list or in uh
encoding Theory which is called
um distance amplification so what this
yeah it is it's uh it's also sort of a
syntactic operation kind of like folding
is in in the sense that you're sort of
redefining where registers are where
symbols are so it's also going to work
for sort of similar reasons that the CSS
codes work
um and uh of course strongly that it
really works as one of the main
technical parts of our paper and um yeah
applying this technique to our fallen
Quantum codes is how we're going to get
our final result
uh okay
so
um uh a couple of future directions
uh are you know one thing our alphabet
is constant but not binary uh so like I
said long and Smith construct binary
alphabet code uh listed codable codes
that are not efficient but um but the
only ways that we sort of know how to
take quantity coding and boost it to
Unique decoding require uh like
augmenting the registers with like Lucy
go sharing components so it would seem
to require new ideas to get you all the
way down to a binary alphabet I think it
would be an interesting question
um and uh also sort of on the other on
the other side uh classically the fact
that you can list the code up to the
Singleton bound ended up being like a
really useful fact
um and uh
I think it's an interesting question of
whether anything similar can hold
quantumly uh where now we don't even uh
need a list right because you can
uniquely decode
um uh at least approximately
okay so that's all that I wanted to say
so oh so I went a little bit fast but um
but yeah I couldn't open load of
questions I guess
uh great thanks uh thanks Sam that was a
very nice talk so um are there any
questions
and
okay so barring any questions maybe we
can we can
oh there is a question among the here
let me
okay uh go ahead Victor can you can you
ask a question uh
um so for risk of sounding naive this
was a bit fast for me
um let me just see if I got what I got
out of this
um you show that
approximate codes cannot beat but
achieve Quantum Singleton bound
approximate Quantum American codes
cannot be but achieve the Singleton
Bound in terms of decoding
radius and the codes that you construct
are basically CSS codes constructed out
of folded read Solomon codes
yeah in in some sense yeah but but I
guess sort of that was one thing you
can't CSS folded read Solomon codes
together so you have to fold the CSS
code but that was that was what I was
trying to get across at the end is is
that you can fold the Cs code and then
in some sense you you end up with with
two folded read solving codes uh kind of
interestingly
um but yeah yeah exactly this this is
the the basic idea sorry yeah so it's a
general you you had to generalize the
Machinery of of of of getting a Quantum
Code out of folded read Solomon codes
because and thanks for saying this I
hadn't realized folded read Solomon
codes are not linear so the CSS
construction cannot be applied right
right right thanks yeah there's no paper
right no no it will should be out like
next week
uh yes
okay uh yeah uh Anand
oh hi hi
sorry there's actually a problem with
the audio
okay
um thanks for a nice talk I think we're
um
just a little confused where is the step
exactly where you go from being a list
decodable to Unique decodable I think I
sort of missed where that happens
yeah sorry I uh uh so that's that's what
this what this sort of rapper is so so
we have our our list we take our list
according uh decodable code and then we
um we use like sort of this usual trick
where you authenticate your message
um uh in order to sort of see the list
down to a unique elements so uh yeah
oops is it obvious why that so that
location just tells you whether an error
has occurred or not yeah exactly no no
yeah so so okay so um uh
uh
basically okay if you if you
authenticate your message and then you
encode it in a list code right then now
uh okay at least in the classical case
imagine I could just like you know list
the code and then get out my list of
possible Corrections now I can just go
you know all okay each of these these
Corrections are like authenticated
messages though like they live in the
authenticated space so now I just check
each of them and only one of them is
going to be is going to say is going to
is going to say yes good this is like
really the right thing
um by the security properties of our
Authenticator
let's see yeah yeah yeah maybe I should
have uh talked more about that
um but uh
right
so in the quantum setting of course you
know now we're not getting the actual
list of authenticated States now we're
getting a list of possible errors but
but we show that this is it actually is
okay basically what you can do is like
you know go through your list of
possible Corrections one by one trying
them and then checking the
authentication and then and then trying
them and checking authentication and
then using like a gentle measurement
argument to say that that you want to
destroy your your uh your message in the
process yeah
very close okay thanks and that helped a
lot yeah thanks for the question this is
a good uh so Andrew do you want to and
ask
uh sure thanks thank you for the nice
talk
um uh one of the things we say about
Quantum error correction that it's
important to learn what the errors are
but not learn about the state because
you couldn't encode superposition States
and uh classically uh it's also valuable
uh not necessarily from a necessary
point of view but from an efficiency
point of view to do that you know we
have a classical repetition code for
example to be more efficient to do
Center extraction by measuring parity of
neighboring bits as opposed to doing a
majority of vote measuring law and doing
it that way and I was wondering if these
uh schemes that you've developed for
approximate uh list decoding for these
codes can fold back to use folds in a
different way to um classical decoding
to lead to uh more efficient classical
list decoding algorithms or things like
that is there a way to interpret them
that way
um
so uh my inclination is say probably no
uh just because uh because I think the
main like uh uh like what we do to me is
is mostly like you know
kind of coming up with a way to take
like list decodable classical codes and
then turn those into the list to go to a
Quantum codes you know so um so we're
really uh like using everything we can
get out of classical codes to uh
to build our Quantum codes
um
yeah so sometimes you can think of for
example stabilizer codes as like
additive codes over you know GF whatever
if you're doing not just using you know
qubits and I didn't know if there was
any value you know a way to think about
these codes is classical additive code
and say
um uh yeah yeah not that I know about it
I don't know I'm not sure though
um
uh
yeah
so I guess I guess one other thing is um
uh where I thought you were going at
first was um you know classically
economy this like you as you said
there's this requirement that you have
uh like this local and
distinguishability property
um right uh whereas that's not true
classically at all so that's kind of
exactly what these robust secret sharing
schemes are asking for though right it's
uh like secret sharing schemes are like
saying okay well if you think of quantum
American instead as requiring both uh
error tolerance and like secrecy against
local views then like this then showing
is like the right analogous thing to
Quantum error correction and um and you
know interestingly actually uh uh this
robust signal sharing schemes are
subject to something more similar to to
the quantum column here the quantum
columns here in uh
in terms of upper bounds so
so yeah
I don't know if that might not be
related to what you're asking that much
but
that was interesting as well yeah and I
was thinking if there was a way for it
to give back to classical codes at all
yeah yeah that's sort of yeah yeah I
guess yeah it's for that for that thing
I think
um uh my yeah I guess I would the reason
why my inclination is to say no is just
because because like uh our work is all
you know our the work for us is all
about like taking existing classical
things and then figuring out how to how
to like look at them in the right way to
get the quantum thing out of it but but
uh so it's maybe maybe you could do
something like that but but it's not
clear to me right yeah I wasn't I wasn't
thinking you'd get any improvements in
terms of limits of you know these rates
and things like that but maybe just uh
you know getting up to like this half
rate that you could get to classically
you might be able to use more efficient
ski you know a simpler decoding
circuitry which can be very practical
for classical codes yeah
um
yeah
thanks
um
so so
um
okay let's see if there's so so one one
other uh thing I think
um in terms of the in terms of the list
decoding
um Quantum list decoding uh code that
you that you define that's not
approximate right the approximation
comes in the envelope is it yes yeah
exactly yeah yeah the approximation uh
comes in
uh here when when we from the
authenticator in the robust sequel
sharing scheme great yeah so so yeah we
you can list the code exactly yeah
um
are there any other any other questions
oh there's a question let me just uh I
think Chennai has a question too
oh China do you want to go ahead by life
again uh yeah hey Sam
um hey can you tell me a little bit
about what the um logical
that flips in Phase flips look like for
this code because and and I'm sort of
missing how those connect to like the
distance radius so maybe if you could
elucidate a little on what those look
like
um on uh sorry on the the bid flips and
phase uh like if I was to encode
something and then I wanted to apply
like a logical bit flip what would that
look like what does that unitary
transformation look like like a logical
bit flip yeah
um
yeah
um
uh
that's a good question I think when it
would correspond to some Pali but I
think it's not clear what exactly it
would correspond to especially because
so if you want to so you're talking
about are you talking about the list
codes or the or the final approximate
codes
the the final yeah so with the final
approximate codes uh right because
there's this like authentication going
on uh you would really have to uh like
it seems like it would be something kind
of complicated like you have to apply
some logical uh operation that like does
something on the SP on the like code
space of both the the code and like the
authenticated uh the authentication
space
um if that makes any sense
so the the thing that sort of confused
me and um maybe I'm just missing
something Elementary is I thought if the
logical operation was a Paulie then I
could sort of Imagine uh someone going
uh term by term by term applying uh
terms of the police and eventually he'll
get from one logical
state to another logical state right if
he applies enough power he's like yeah
you know he gets further and further and
then he comes back down but somewhere at
the halfway point
um if if the operations are probably he
should switch from answering
um State one to answering state two
right
um right but that seems intention with
the distance
um the radius being you know like near
the bound here so I was sort of confused
by this maybe you can say a few things
um let's see uh let me let me see if I
can if I can understand the question and
uh and think of a good response also
looks like I don't know if Louis if you
if you have any thoughts on this also
feel free to weigh in
um yeah I was just gonna as to like the
first thing you asked I think
so the codes we end up getting are a
basically like a a classical Ensemble of
stabilizer codes
so The Logical operation I think would
be if you have the secret key you know
which of these stabilizer codes you're
in
so you can just apply like The Logical
operations for that stabilizer code
um
I'm not sure if that answered
um I guess I guess when uh
[Music]
okay so so you're saying that that um
that this view of like applying paulies
one by one
um
uh is like
uh
you know so seems like it's
um you know would fit into this picture
but you're saying that it doesn't seem
consistent with the fact that uh that
you have decoding radius all the way up
to the distance something like this yeah
yeah exactly yeah
yeah
um
so maybe I'm not sure but maybe one way
to reconcile these things is that your
approximate thing comes from The
Ensemble average after we average the
keys and
so this intuition that is suddenly if
you sort of fix a key at some point you
will cross over to a different uh
logical state but but somehow the way
that happens is very different for
different keys so when you average
so because you do these policies without
knowing which key it was like if you're
trying to convert one state to the other
you don't know the key so since you
don't know the key for most Keys you
will be actually
going to a place where where you started
with is the only correct place
but there would be but if you knew the
key you can certainly go to
yeah well I think yeah I think I think
that's right
um I think what you need to do is if you
don't know the key you need to look at
enough registers so you can extract the
key from the secret sharing
and then once you know it then you can
do the right thing but that's like a a
many qubit or many cudit operation
um and so if you're just guessing then
yes you'll go off and you'll get
something wrong and it'll just be
clearly wrong and you can't be corrected
but if you have enough then you can look
at them all together find the right key
and then you can do the right thing
thanks yeah yeah thanks I think that's a
good that seems like uh definitely the
right answer to me
that's great
um Victor did you still have a question
or uh
your hands still up
no okay good
um
great uh
well that was uh that was a very nice
um both both are very nicely done talk
you know very nicely dissected set of
ideas and great questions so no but
maybe if you if you stop sharing your
slides we can move to the panel
so so we have a great panel today
um uh Debbie learned from University of
Waterloo who as as you already know was
uh uh you know very you know very
appropriate for this panel she defined
uh Quantum list decoding quotes in
addition to you know whatever control
tolerance and
and photography and so on
and of course we have uh we have venkat
who uh who I think uh you know uh well
he's he's first of all uh uh you know
one of the senior fellows at the quantum
Institute but he's he's also uh
um you know played a pivotal role in
defining
Quantum classical list decoding and the
best codes there and you know lots of
other stuff so so banquet and then uh
and then uh we have uh Steve flamia on
the panel who is uh who is now at AWS
and um he brings a you know
much more of a physics sensibility to
this subject you know he's worked on
uh uh condensed matter Theory
topological uh phases and of course
error correction tensor networks so
really a great panel I wonder if we can
if if there's somebody who's
um who's uh pinning the
the uh
um the videos of the panelists
um
sorry do we have uh
they're pinned the videos are pinned
um
how come I'm not seeing them
um so is everybody else seeing that
pinned they look good to me okay okay
okay great great so maybe um
you know could we uh
uh just start with um
um
you know comments from Debbie would you
like to would you like to start and
sure I have some questions
on the result is still um I think the
first uh is what happened to the key
size
because if you need to authenticate the
symbols
the authentication key has to be the
symbols themselves have to be encrypted
by a classical key there is a result by
Daniel and others that in order to
authenticate a corner message you have
to encrypt so there seem to be a lower
bound on the key size and then when you
have to perform secret sharing Robert
secretary sharing on the keys it seems
to run up your uh symbol size by a
certain amount yeah so it would be nice
to see a little detail on that
um the second question is that following
up on the discussion earlier about
um knowing the key and knowing what code
you have and therefore you can try to
perform a logical Party by running the
symbols running on a physical party one
by one
if you use classical key
is there some notion at which the fs3
can look at the key
without changing them
and then using the key to
defeat your result because then the
episode may have some idea what random
code is being
used
um again sorry I may have missed some of
the detail how it actually work out yeah
um that's good with uh so okay so so
you're saying
um
if the addressee learns something about
the keys then then they could use this
to uh
to defeat the the code
yeah I'm a little confused about the
fact that the key are classical and
somehow
it is is it sent in the open or is it
also
encoded as Economist sorry so so that's
that's the point of the River Secret
sharing scheme so the Rustica sharing
scheme is there to to hide the key from
the adversary while still transmitting
it to the receiver so the Rustica
training scheme has this property that
as long as the adversary doesn't look at
too many registers
um the key looks completely random from
their point of view
uh and furthermore whatever they do to
whatever they whatever adversarial
attack they do the recipient given the
whole message the whole message will
still be able to recover the right keys
with high probability
in that case you seem to imply that the
corruption model is that the adversary
uh
cannot even look at the message uh yes
yes the Eritrea cannot even look at
which which is necessary in the quantum
setting because if you can sort of look
at like if the Outer Circle look at the
entire Quantum message and they could
measure it and like collapse it right
so so um
so yeah so you have encrypted the Costco
key as a Quantum message
uh yeah you could you could think of it
that way yeah
um
right
right yeah I think I think you're
bringing up a really good point that's
there's this there is a kind of a bit of
like a modeling mismatch I think between
classical air correction and Quantum air
correction which is that a lot of times
classical you think of the adversary as
looking at the whole message and then
perturbing only part of it whereas
quantumly in some sense it doesn't
really make sense to look at the whole
message right because if if the
adversary could actually like measure
the whole message then then they were
destroyed
so so uh yeah
so we're we're assuming that you know
we're assuming that the adversary can
only look at a small fraction of the
message
uh
and then uh what happened to the key
size
oh yeah okay and then the key size so um
I guess I think that the the reason is
uh the answer to your question is that
um is the mainly because we use this
thing called purity testing codes which
are like slightly different than message
authentication codes uh basically like
we're able to to reduce to the case
where like sort of only pallies are
happening
um and uh and it turns out that you can
build like pretty like very efficient
purity testing codes
um
and uh
right right
so so it ends up that the keys won't
actually be too large
um yeah the confusion come from the fact
that uh the authentication code by
um Corporal and uh
um
has the feature that you use the purity
test code to as a middle step yeah and
in the end it's still a it only counts
for a small portion of the key
yeah that is the part of the key that's
uh Choice message length the quantum
message length and then that can be
recycled so the overall use is small but
the initial key is actually big I just
wonder how yeah let's get around that
problem yeah or uh so if I'm under I I
might be misunderstanding but but so we
only we only use the purity testing part
we don't need to like fully authenticate
so this is so this is why I put I put
authentication in quotes just because
it's like morally it's something like
authentication but really really the
purity testing code was the only thing
that we use
um so in some sense like the the the
code around it like the listing of a
code around it takes care of the other
um yeah it takes care of the other
issues I guess okay thanks is that yeah
I don't know if that if that helps also
if I mean Thiago and Lily might have a
uh if you guys have any thoughts on this
question I might uh missing something
but uh I don't know does that does that
answer your question
correct
so I might also be able to later comment
on some connections of this to the
classical thing so I you know yeah yeah
I mean this particular part of how you
interface how you get a unique decodable
thing out of listing there are some
classical analogs of that two in
restricted models and um do you want to
go ahead thank God and do it now give
your comments now uh sure yeah um yeah
so I guess there is this question of how
do you interface this list decodable
thing with uh this authentication and I
must say in the quantum setting I'm also
a bit you know fuzzy on that but because
it's I guess things are more subtle in
this thing uh but in the classical case
you can have this model where the you do
a randomized encoding of the message and
the adversary is allowed to see the
message but not the internal Randomness
you use to encode so so so it doesn't
see the code word but sees the message
and the message goes to one a
distribution of code words and in this
case uh one can reduce list decoding to
Unique decoding and essentially the idea
is something similar you use
um some sort of an authentication code
some specific form
and in fact one thing which works nicely
is that if you use a linear uh code
um then the set of possible errors does
not depend on the um the set of possible
offsets of the message only depend on
the error cost
so because of this you sort of break
some dependence and in some sense you
only need this authentication to be good
for some fixed number of offsets which
you can build just you know without any
crypto tools or anything it's it's a
purely sort of information theoretic
fact that you can build
um such authentication codes for such
algebraic manipulations essentially you
don't allow arbitrary distortions you
allow some linear operations
and and and so then you can essentially
do the same thing you can take random
key apply this thing which I think is
called an algebraic manipulation
detection code it's used in some crypto
settings AMD so you just apply this AMD
code you do this decoding and only one
of the offsets will match with high
probability so you'll get your unique
decoding but of course the key thing
here is that you restrict adversary to
um make the errors before seeing the
full code right so in the classical
setting it makes sense for the adversary
to see the full code word but you don't
you disallow that the errors have to be
picked before
um you know independent of the
randomness in the encoder which is
somewhat reasonable model because and
their Randomness need not be shared with
the recipient or anything it's
completely local to The Encore so so
there is that um
connection yeah
um
and actually in this context I had a
sort of a question or more like a you
know just thinking out loud is that
um
in the classical case we don't know so
one way to get binary codes which
achieve this optimal trade-off would be
to take a binary list decodable code
apply this thing which I just said this
sort of AMD trick and you will
immediately get a uniquely decodable
codes in this somewhat restricted but
still reasonable model
and
um I was wondering if you know you
mentioned some obstacles in getting
analogous result for binary you know
qubit codes so if you did have your
dream list decodable code in the binary
world
then
um is there something you one could do
um so I was just you know something I
thought yeah maybe it doesn't have a
clean answer but yeah yeah that's a good
a good question yeah like suppose you
had your your dream binary list of
credible code to whatever limit you can
do that too uh yeah I mean I guess the
thing is you can't do this robust signal
sharing trick right because that's going
to blow up the alphabet so yeah it seems
to me like the only thing that you could
do
off the bat would be you know relax your
model and say you're allowed like a side
Channel
but I think it was a really good
question of whether and I think and
someone even suggested to Me Maybe one
possibility of doing this recently
um like but I think it's interesting
question of how do you write you might
do this without you know relaxing the
model or or having a a
increasing the alphabet size
um but somehow you have to like so I
mean okay maybe like the obvious like
the maybe the most direct thing to try
would be to something like somehow you
still have to hide your keys in other
qubits you know like maybe you could put
the keys in more qubits and just
lengthen the code and then somehow
scramble them so that you don't know
where they are but uh I don't know if
something that can like that can be made
to work I haven't I haven't really
thought about it yet
foreign
[Music]
there were also a couple of other things
I was intrigued by taking sort of giving
back to classical but I think we can
come back to that maybe you know maybe
Steve wants to say yeah or something
um yeah there's just been a ton of
discussion I'm not sure I have that much
to add actually uh I do have a question
though is it
um is it known that you need to expand
the alphabet to apply these robust
secret sharing schemes is that necessary
or known to be necessary
uh so I guess what is what is necessary
is you need to expand the alphabet uh
somewhat like the closer you want to get
to the Singleton bound uh you need to
expand the alphabet
um
yeah the exact trade-off though we
haven't
uh pinned down yet I see
um uh yeah yes there's also I guess
there's also the same thing catapults
with robot secretion so I think if
that's what you're actually like so it's
it's independent of whether or not you
use that specific scheme which does
expand the alphabet it's just step it's
separately known that you you have to
blow up the alphabet size a little bit
but it's not known what the bounds are
yeah so yeah so you have to blow up the
alphabet size in order to get closer to
the quantum Singleton bound definitely
so I guess the question is okay if you
fix yourself to Cubit alphabets
for instance then there's some there's
some it's not the quantum extinguishing
bound so there's some bound you can you
can reach yeah the question is kind of
what what is it I guess
um but yeah
yes
um and your current best parameters
scaled like they were exponential in the
distance to one minus r over two yeah
exactly yeah exactly yeah
yeah so yeah it would be nice to improve
that I guess there's nothing known about
how that should yeah okay so yeah so
here's a good question I think um I mean
maybe I shouldn't like claim this yet
but I think if you do there's some like
here is the kind of arguments you can
make that make it uh seem like actually
that's necessary
um I'm not I don't think that it's
actually known that you need uh that you
need like X to grow exponential in the
alphabet to go exponential and one over
the slack but um but uh I'm pretty sure
that that that's that's a necessity yeah
what's the argument for that
uh it's actually something
basically another another argument like
this snow cloning uh this is the snow
cloning one that I gave on that on that
like third slide
um
uh
let's see
a quick comment there is that for the
list decoding itself you do need the
alphabet to be exponential in this one
over gamma but of course you might build
these Quantum things without relying on
display coding so so at least the way
they are approaching it by starting with
this decoding right off the bat I think
um you you do face this big blog and
that is purely just an information
Theory sort of counting argument that
you need basically okay but
um
but it doesn't have to be exponential in
one over gamma to the five it only I
think has to be exponential on our gamma
so there's definitely something
yeah lose there but the high level trade
off that
you should really think of it as the
number of bits in the alphabet and that
has to be one over comma I think that
comes for some information Theory reason
now for the approximate error correction
I don't know and it will be actually
quite interesting if there is a
separation so
interesting
okay yeah thanks I didn't realize that
was true for list decoding but that's
uh yeah
um
anything else uh but uh Debbie did you
have more to say
anyone else
yes I it is awkward for me to ask a
question about my own result
but then how did we get around the
problem not expanding they finally over
but we didn't get close to the single
then bound and there's the we did not
even get close to the Rings found
upon three something times uh the number
of qubits that we send
um and we use a key which is logarithmic
in the block length and we can sneak the
key into the transmission to regenerate
it
and we do not know whether that is
necessary at all
in the Costco setting if you try to do
the same for a binary classical
symmetric binary FSR Channel
and you try to use this decoding and try
to approach a similar bound we learned
that it seems to be necessary to use
some key so I I get I get a little
curious how these all come together
um
yeah
um so maybe if you don't have do you
know sorry did you want to answer
Debbie's question or did you have some
thoughts to share Sam no no no
um
since I was uh given the role of the
token physicist I maybe I'll try to ask
a bit of a physicsy question or just
maybe motivate some thinking along some
uh physicsy lines
um
there's really kind of two
uh local dimensions for subsystems that
people like to think about and one of
them is two
but I guess we're not going to get very
close to the Singleton bound if we're
stuck at two apparently but the other is
infinity
um and that's because there are these
beautiful codes called bosonic codes
and the mathematics of these is quite
different because you're encoding in a
system that has ostensibly an infinite
number of levels
um what you do physically instead to
make this reasonable is you put some
kind of energy constraint or something
so that you can't access all of these
levels
um but I'm wondering uh if there are
ways to derive some results that exploit
these types of codes directly
um
I mean I realize this is a theoretical
result and uh we're not about to
implement these codes uh in the next few
days or weeks or probably years
um but I think it would be extremely
interesting if they were made to be a
little bit more native
by exploiting some inner codes that were
bosonic codes
I think the reason I think this is
interesting
um
is because people are actually trying to
build these codes and they've been quite
successful there have been experiments
recently where people have shown that if
you take an oscillator
and you encode a qubit into that
oscillator
um then the qubit can have a lower
logical error rate than the US than the
bare error rates of the oscillator in a
specific sense so this isn't quite the
same as an error correction experiment
where you take pen qubits and get out k
qubits but it's morally very similar and
it's also technically extremely
challenging and if you can use this to
get better qubits you can concatenate
into a code
as well
um so yeah I mean I wanted to just maybe
motivate the idea that it's worth
thinking about large alphabets uh but
that the physical way to try to do so is
to think of those alphabets as embedding
into some
um harmonic oscillator or or you know
some some sort of physical system that
has
um
uh that natively contains all of these
levels and people have thought a lot
about these codes I'm not sure if it's
possible to weave your arguments
together uh with some of these things
directly but um it seems to me like it's
something we're thinking about
more more of a comment than a question
oh yeah that's that's a really
interesting point I I wasn't aware of
these bosonic codes really
um I guess on a related note I know that
that Louis has been thinking a lot about
uh making these codes that we've
constructed lapc
I'm using these similar I guess it's
kind of a related thing of like you know
how physically implementable is it
um seems like there's some promising
stuff there yeah I was going to ask that
too actually that um if you can instead
of using CSS codes I mean it seems to
work for General CSS codes right but
we're trying to follow all the
constraints that are on them but yeah uh
these balanced product codes and things
like this rcss so it may be possible to
um improve some of the performance with
respect to the weight of the stabilizers
of the code
um yeah
yeah
definitely
mm-hmm
great um any anyone else have comments
so
um
just one quick Point since I think it
was Andrew who asked about whether this
can give back to classical things so I
guess even in classical one can imagine
asking an approximate error correction
question where it'll only make sense for
say big big fields or something but
um you could imagine you know you know
big Prime field and you could allow some
sort of like L Infinity error so you
could sort of make a mistake in every
position but then you make some sort of
bounded error and that seems to be the
flavor of what you're getting at because
you you know you
because if you of course make a small
number of Hamming errors you can of
course correct it with just a pre-code
so that that's cannot be done in the
classical case but if you allow more
continuous errors like some Infinity
error or something so so do you have a
sense of whether
um
and also at a sort of a higher level I
was wondering how much one can sort of
black box from classical coding to
approximate qec in this thing right so
in the sense that is it just list
decoding plus this or I mean how much
you know in the to the sense that I mean
one of the powerful things with the CSS
framework was that it told you exactly
what you needed in the classical thing
and you're done yeah and which is also
good because it allows you to then
inspect it and change it and which
exactly as you guys did did the folded
version Etc so I'm sort of wondering of
course it's still you know early days
after this result but it would be nice
to introspect and see how much one can
model array some of these components
right so to see uh
yeah that's a really good a really good
punch really good question I think I
think
okay yeah I'm just gonna say so I think
I think for the most part it's it's very
black box like like uh uh okay so we
technically for the last step to get
constant to get constant uh alphabet
size we're going to require some like
list recoverability property uh
um but I think yeah for the most part I
think it's like you should be able to
very much like black box away uh yeah
like whether it's read Solomon or some
other uh
uh yeah code I don't think it should
matter very much
um
there are a lot of restrictions though
it's like it has to be you know it has
to be linear and then it has to have
list decoding
um yeah
yeah I guess it sounded like
um you know go ahead thank God I'm just
finish this automation then I would love
to hear what your comments so maybe I
want to say that the question is also
where you modernize right I mean of
course uh I mean I'm happy that you make
less decoding you know you know a key
black box but I wonder whether it should
really be some form of approximate
classical error correction in the unique
world and say that if you have this then
you get quantum and then you kind of
build that using list decoding perhaps
or maybe not so I'm just so I'm also
thinking whether you could for example
solve this approximate error correction
problem with say l Infinity error up to
the Singleton bound uniquely
um right in the classical World whether
that could maybe that's the
um maybe that's the right level of
abstraction yeah kind of then pass to
the quantum I mean I don't know I'm just
wondering yeah no I think I think I get
it I think that's a yeah that's a good
point I think also another alternative
potential sort of like uh classical
analog is a server signaturing thing so
I think I mentioned earlier raw single
sharing seems to be subject to similar
bounds as approximate Quantum codes so
uh I think it seems plausible to me that
you know maybe there's some way to
rather than doing our like list decoding
authentication construction maybe you
could just take robust secret sharing
classical sharing and directly get
approximate Quantum air correction out
of it uh so maybe it'd be related thing
to to try but I wasn't able to make this
work so
okay
um
um sorry Victor seems to have a comment
again uh do you do you want to go ahead
and ask your question yeah I just want
to butt in and uh piggyback off of
Steve's comment uh about bosonic codes
uh bosonic codes stabilizer codes are
based off of lattices and hyperplanes in
RN so
the stuff you guys want to do on the
Quan on the classical side like folding
and list decoding uh should probably be
looked at in RN and maybe it already has
I just don't know but that would be a
step probably toward making Quantum
versions of these things
foreign
okay
um I I guess um before we end uh Andrew
had a question that he put in the chat
before he had to leave
which um
because you know where he he asked about
XYZ product codes which I didn't didn't
know about so maybe one of you does uh
we generalize CSS codes by combining
three classical codes
and he he asked whether those can be
folded in sequence in some way and also
generate approximate Quantum codes that
saturate the quantum Singleton bound so
um
maybe maybe my first first question
would be does anybody here know about
XYZ codes and what they are because I
don't and
um I think Anthony leverier is on this
call and uh I think he's an author of
this paper
um
maybe he wants to say something
uh Anthony uh you
maybe he's too shy
um okay
yeah I mean I guess uh
uh I I guess the point is that
you know you could imagine correcting X
errors and Z errors separately with a
standard CSS type Construction
um but you might want to consider
correcting y errors and of course you
conceptually these are redundant because
x times Z gives you y uh but the reason
you might want to correct them
separately is because maybe your poly
channel has some uh bias and this
happens actually in a lot of physical
architectures some error rates
um are biased towards some errors rather
than others so you can kind of
symmetrize over the Pali algebra a
little bit
um when you when you correct y as being
a product of x and z you're kind of
um morally hoping that the Y errors
occur uh like like conceptually what's
happening is you're saying an X error
with probability p and a z error with
probability P combined to give you a y
error
um but the way you would but but then
you're sort of implicitly asking it to
occur with probability P Squared you
don't have to of course your decoder you
could try to tune your decoder or
something but
these codes try to symmetrize the Pali
algebra a little bit better or to give
you more finer grained control over
um
how the power to correct X versus Y
versus Z is distributed throughout the
code so I think that's a motivating
reason to consider these codes
um so they're it's like giving you one
more thing to fold into the product
Construction
um and if Anthony were uh
here uh well he's here but maybe he
stepped away or maybe he's too shy he
could tell us all about these and
whether uh
whether it would work but he's not here
so
okay
um uh Thiago did you have something to
say
yeah I had a quick question so um the
um the techniques in this paper they
they allow us to ask an analogous
question of list decoding from erasures
even for for Quantum codes and and very
small even binary alphabets
um and this is something that venka has
done has done extensive work in a
classical context but I did want to more
generally ask about
um different types of error models
whether say with biased noise or or just
not strictly restricting to erasers and
adversarial errors and I was wondering
whether you guys have any ideas or the
panelists have any ideas about how these
techniques or or related techniques
could be used for say if you knew that X
errors occurred with some biased
probability
any thoughts um sounds like a pretty big
question to us right so
I mean my initial reaction is I mean
just the obvious one which you all know
which is that of course these two codes
correct different numbers of X and Y Z
errors right so at least if we knew X
errors are more likely then maybe you
can get you can pick one of the codes in
a more skewed way so the DX is higher
than d y or d z or something yeah yeah
but uh otherwise I mean I don't have a
more thoughtful answer than that so
actually is that uh if if it was if you
have that static case is that the
optimal thing to do or is there
something even better you can do
is that known
you know what he suggested sounds like I
mean it'll be the first thing you would
suggest but it probably might not be the
right thing I mean often is not in these
cases right so
yeah and there was also a related things
which correcting why errors like somehow
when you when you only correct X errors
and Z errors you kind of pay some Factor
two or something if you want to correct
all
um errors on up to ebits or something
like you need to be able to correct both
ex errors and Z errors sort of
simultaneously and and maybe the
discrepancy is because of this why and
maybe this XYZ codes address that I'm
curious I'll look them up but I never
heard of them before so
my main concern is that an error model
like this is not fair adversary at all
you have to trust that indeed there is
largely uh X error versus Z error
um and that seems to walk away from the
whole
spirit that was trying to cope with as
much of a zero error as possible when we
talk about aircrafting codes rather than
say Channel coding yeah
but I remember there was one talk in
this colloquium series maybe six months
ago or something I forget the title I'm
sorry which actually said that in some
physical implementations it seems
erasures are more likely uh is what is
happening so it sort of gave some
renewed interest into aeration codes so
so I guess to the extent that you want
the models to reflect
the current physical implementation and
there seems to be a wide variety of this
based on which implementation people are
talking about right so since it's about
developing so
so everything more possibility for
dialogue between the specific
implementation and the model one should
think about than say in the classical
case where it seems relatively well
trodden that you have three or four
models
most likely you have a bunch of erasures
and then there are some also unknown
errors around
great uh
well uh
if there are no other no other comments
maybe uh uh thank you thanks uh one more
comment Steve have already walked away
at least in house businesses here but
um there is a whole uh community of
people also working on something very
similar in title called approximate air
correction in which case uh they look at
one specific air correcting code but uh
it satisfy the air question Criterion
approximately
um because the quantum error is
continuous
so you can Define these Notions and you
can talk about a lot of different
scenario in which you fix one code but
the correction is approximate
for all sorts of reasons it looks very
different from the kind of approximation
study here in in the more cryptographic
setting when the approximation comes
from
the randomness in the code chosen
I do wonder if there is it looks very
different so a fund there seemed to be
two slightly different subject I do want
the is is anyone having different
thought that this can be more connected
than
what it looks on Surface
yeah that's a good question I'm also not
very familiar with this other uh sort of
line of work but but I think I had the
same impression as you did that they're
they sort of have different goals in
mind so like usually these code what I
was seeing it looked like these codes
usually have distance that's like
logarithmic or something in your block
length uh if I understood correctly
um
I guess it's like they were interested
in questions like you know what wouldn't
a natural like exist like naturalizing
code uh what kind of approximate
encryption properties would it have as
opposed to us which is like constructing
a an approximate air current code with
the best properties you can get
so this is this is what they seem like
okay
um
well then for you know it's it's a it's
a really good question I don't I don't
know if we have if we have the
expedition
right here to resolve the question so
maybe
a good question to bring up and we can
explore it offline
okay
um
well uh
okay so is it there is a
any anything else you'd like to discuss
before we call it a day
otherwise uh thanks Sam for a great talk
and thanks to the panelists um uh for
for the comments and uh thank you all
for showing up even though even even
though you're you're missing a World Cup
match um uh so
um but you know next week uh next
Tuesday is the is the semi-finals and
that's you know we can't you know we we
can we can uh we can deal with this
round but not with the semi-finals so uh
there's no colloquium next week and then
since that was going to be the final
colloquium that's it for this semester
so uh great to see you all and uh we'll
meet again next semester
thanks okay great thanks
foreign